drugs is like what everybody turns to
and then i like i said they call this
the city of hope
i remember one time somebody took some
spray paint and knocked off the h
and put a d there they and made it to
say the sun that coming in say the city
of dope
all right matthew matthew uh where are
you from originally where were you born
i was born in manchester kentucky and
tell me about your
family you had both your parents growing
up um i did until i was about
four um and then i have a step dad
who actually used to be married to my
dad's sister
um so my mom left my dad and
my aunt and her husband got split up
which would be my uncle by marriage and
my mom and uh
my you know used to be uncle by marriage
i have been married for 20 some years
now since
96. and tell me about your childhood
um so growing up in clay county
it was pretty um you know it was
pretty boring childhood tell me about
clay county
clay county they call it it's one of the
poorest counties in the country
absolutely they call it uh the city of
hope but really it's kind of it's pretty
hopeless here
um and you know sometimes i pray that
for all the kids around here because
they're just it is a
really tough place to grow up there's no
positive role models
you know anywhere you go there's very
few positive role models
let me put it that way there's a couple
but you know it's just not a place for
that i feel kids should be very few jobs
no jobs at all um you know the jobs that
are here are sold up you do have to go
at least 45 minutes to the towns around
here and you might get lucky and find a
job
but even those are are rare and you know
if you
get a job there and mess it up you don't
have no options after that
so usually everybody will mess up their
first couple jobs and
um so yeah it's pretty rough on the work
around here
so you you got how far in school um
i was in the seventh grade i failed the
seventh grade four times
um and they automatically moved me to
the ninth grade
and i did officially make it to the
tenth grade
um when that should have been my senior
year because they moved me up a few
grades
but i got expelled every year since the
seventh grade
there wasn't one year that i ever got to
see the end of a school year i got the
full expulsion
for for what um fighting uh
drugs um a little bit everything
so you got into drugs at what age um
when i was uh
very young you know the people around me
drugs is real normal around kids uh here
you know i remember school teachers from
down here coming to buy drugs
from my parents um and i would go to
school and be there
um and see the teachers i know that
they'd come to it was just real
normal by the time i was five like you
could hand me any
pill that's out there and they can say
what's this and i could
that's a xanax that's a percocet that's
a lower tap so i knew
you know that was i was raised around it
it's five years old
um yeah so you know it was uh and pills
pills were big
then right absolutely um there was no
heroin
or nothing down here that was oxycontin
was the biggest thing
and then the the percocet 30s and they
absolutely
destroyed this place and the church is
trying to get together and
places trying to get together to make it
um
to fight against the drugs and stuff but
even our government
like totally went downhill um in this
town like we had 14 of our we had the
the mayor uh go to jail um
all kinds of stuff you know like they
buy votes um you you can get a vote for
20 bucks down here and there's people
that all these elected officials
they hand out money and you just they
and
so say you're a runner to get votes
they'll hand you a stack of money and
you go get everybody you can
hey i got 20 bucks to uh let me jump in
the car with me not taking you
vote for who i want you to vote for so
like it's this whole town is
twisted like even the people that are in
authority
um just ain't ain't all together neither
so where'd your life go after so
so after um you know when i was uh
18 years old um i went to jail
the first time the big boy jail um adult
joe
here in clay county for something really
stupid got out
um in a couple hours and then shortly
after that um i went to jail for
felonious assault they said i broke
somebody's legs and it was really
a self-defense and i didn't touch the
guy's legs
um he just fell and couldn't get back up
after he attacked me
and i like kicked him off on me so my
punishment for that
was it was it was a class b
felony um and that's five to ten years
here in kentucky um so
my punishment they made a deal with me
that they would drop it to a misdemeanor
um put me on unsupervised probation
um if i the terms of the probation were
to stay out of clay county for three
years
and they've actually my parents were at
that time were already kicked out for
five years both of them for trafficking
um so like you know that's something
they do a lot it doesn't make people
leave
clay county when they get in trouble
rather than
putting them in in prison they ship them
out uh yep yes sir
um but so then after that
i go to hamilton ohio
and i did five years in prison down
there for robbing a bank
you know it all stems from drugs like um
some of the people you met today when i
was
12 like i had people stick i don't stick
a needle in my arm and shoot me up with
cocaine
when i was 12 years old um i may have
been 13. i'm not quite sure the age but
you know people that were supposed to be
my role models
stuck needles in my arm when i was 13.
so
that's you know and i was in
places where they cooked meth for the
first time at about 14
down here and that was huge down here
meth
because it was a lot cheaper than the
pills and it was a lot more affordable
because
like like i said it's poverty around
nothing but poverty
um people are waiting at their mailboxes
every first of the month
um waiting on a check like if you go out
on the first and the third
there's lines at the mailbox yelling at
each other hey
everybody just waiting on their check
because that's how everybody survived
down here
um so yeah
what drugs are most popular today down
here most popular today is
meth by far um i've i have heard of
heroin being down here
and um but meth is
like got this place destroyed
everybody's shooting up meth and
it's crazy it went from it went from oc
80s
to and cocaine to to meth and
heroin and how do you know i'm 29
29. and you've done a little prison time
yes sir i did uh five years
are you working or have you worked um i
own a business um when i was 24
um you know my dad actually owned a
owned a business here in clay county um
they called him jack the tire man
he was also one elected official
officials i was referring to
um he owned the tire shop and he was
elected as the constable and um
shortly after he was elected for the
constable he actually
i went to i went to prison and i talked
to him and then three months after
i was in jail waiting to go to prison i
got a phone call that the feds had got
my dad and
he was elected official and he got 20
years um for selling
one lower tab and he had a gun they
charged him a carrera
criminal and they gave him 20 years over
one pill down here
so you robbed a bank yes i robbed a bank
and uh how many banks have you robbed um
i got called for one
a good answer it hasn't it um you know
like
i did make a deal that um that a lot of
stuff that i've done
uh when and part of the the deal i made
for five years
um anything that got brought up after i
did my time
wouldn't be uh you know they couldn't
hold against me
but the thing is that's only in the
state of ohio so
you know what so what goes through your
head as you're planning to rob a bank
what's the situation you're desperate
for something drugs no
it was more of an adrenaline thing um i
had
so i've been planning on robbing a bank
for
um six months i've been looking at this
bank for six months um and i actually
knew a couple bank robbers
that got me into it you know getaway
driver
a guy who's robbed multiple banks
um and and you know the getaway driver
and another guy my age
that was their first bank they robbed
with him um
and so i know some bank robbers and i
watched them
um you know and they they talked to me
and told me about the adrenaline you get
from it and how you can go in and in 30
seconds come out with
all kinds of money so and you know it
was a good story like in
they also was talking about how they
took care of their family after they got
out of there
and um it wasn't really they made it so
glorious to me you know when i was a
young
kid and that's how i got into it um so
when but i was planning to rob this
certain bank for
six months and had a great plan would
have definitely
most likely i would have got away with
it can't say definitely but i had a
great plan
um but then one night i was partying
with some girls and i had a bunch of
money
and they asked me how i how did i keep
money like that and i said
come with me and i'll show you and uh i
you know i i said take me to this bank
and they said what you know what floor
and i said i'm going to withdraw some
money
um and that was the first time i got
caught but i actually did
20 xanax and and drunk uh half a
fifth of captain morgan and uh my plan
went out the window i went in with no
mask no
nothing like i threw that i was so high
on xanax and drinking
um that everything i was taught went out
the window
um everything i was told on how to not
get caught robbing a bank went out the
window
you know no face no case no double doors
watch the time limit you know everything
went out the window just
i was it was like i was watching out of
my body
and watching from above like on a video
camera myself
my body just reacted and i went in
uh leaned over the counter this is a
robbery don't make it a murder
give me all the hundreds and fifties um
how much did they give you
um not enough uh it kind of embarrassing
to say they gave me five years to start
with
um and twenty eight hundred dollars so
it was uh it was
like i said i wasn't i wasn't in no
shape to do it
i did get away for a couple more weeks
but uh
like i said i had some girls with me and
that was the dumbest thing i ever could
have done
um and one of them i barely knew so
i got told on i i really like i said
they knew my face
but nobody in that where we was at in
the place we was at knew who i was so
even if i'd been all over the news
um and they everybody see me there's a
really good chance i could have got away
with it
but i had some people that were local to
me
or my new uh that were local to the
community
that was with me and one of them got
scared
and they actually went to the police and
let them know who i was so
that's how i got called i probably still
could have gotten away with it
i was going for a week but then the girl
one of the girls got so worried that if
they didn't step forward
you know that they would be charged with
the same thing that i was charged with
and i found out a few days later one
one of the girls who i knew better than
the other one i knew her for a long
time she said hey she tried to get me to
go to the police station and tell
you last night and i was like are you
serious and
i was still high from the uh for a week
after that you know
and i walked uh to the person's house
and i was going to knock on that door
that wasn't home and i remember going in
i had a bmw then i'd go into their house
and i'd steal everything out of their
house
and throw it in my trunk and drive down
the road and next thing you know uh i'm
about to leave town
um in hamilton ohio i'm about to leave
town
and next thing you know like all these
cops surrounding me somehow uh
those people were in the back of a cop
car the girl and her
she had a boyfriend that was both in the
back of the cop car pointing me out
at a circle k in hamilton and i had no
clue how they knew where i was at
so but that's what happened so you moved
to ohio at one point
yes i moved to ohio when uh i was told
to get out of clay county
so so your arrest record got you kicked
out of town
yep and then uh after i got kicked out
of um
clay county um then in hamilton
that's when i started getting
in a lot of trouble like i remember i
stole a car one day and you know that
hill
we just seen like i don't know if your
audience can
like i'll try to paint a picture of it
or maybe
you can flash a picture of it up i don't
know if you do i don't know yeah
um just you can describe it uh so
there's a
so we my whole family lives up on this
hill um on this holler
and that's what the way a lot of people
are like families are in bunches
um in these hollers so up one side of
the hill
um it's got a it's got a really steep
hill and there's a bank
i mean on that bank i stole this car in
hamilton shortly after i got
kicked out i wasn't supposed to be in
clay county and i drove it up here
um and i sold it for
300 in math and this was a really nice
car
and i'm and this is one of the things
prior to the robbery
um like i said my deal that i made for
my five years
uh because i knew there was a lot more
stuff that could come back on me
that i'd done in hamilton um my lawyer
made sure that i would have immunity for
any crimes
that i did before um i got caught for
the robbery
so that worked out for me do you think
your life would be totally different if
you grew up in a different part of the
country
you know i think my my life would be
totally different
if um if yeah absolutely my life would
be different because
it's just down here there's there's one
thing there's drugs you know
um there's church or drugs and
i did the church thing down here when i
lived here uh
you know that's where you're gonna see
all your friends when you're not at
school at church down here
this is a huge place but everybody's so
far away
it's a small town everybody knows
everybody but it's spread out
really you know really far um in schools
where you see your friends and churches
where you see your friends down here
but then you get that age and
everything around you is nothing but
drugs even going to church
doing drugs so
there's a the church here in manchester
it's the biggest church
you know the i would say the richest
church in manchester
um it's right next to the courthouse
that's where the lawyers and the judges
and
elected officials all go i mean they
have a youth pastor and a youth outreach
program
and the youth pastor there's there was
always stories about him
um touching kids and stuff you know he
was
i believe he's about 35 years old he'd
never
been married and he uh he's a teacher in
kentucky which is right next to
manchester um
his life for involves around kids when i
was in foster care
carrying out here for my parents getting
caught trafficking
he chose like his victims he would
choose problematic kids you know i got
suspended from school every year
um as i said before and he chose
problematic kids to target
and um he asked me in a buddy one night
to stay all night with them on a
saturday
and go to church with him on sunday and
we both looked at each other like
what you want to stay overnight we'll
play ball so we played
he lives right next door to the church
um we played ball in the
outreach center that whole night and
about three o'clock in the morning
we decided to go in and was asleep on
the
couch and well i we lay down
a few hours later my buddy's like matt
matt matt wake up
i wake up and he's like is anybody on
the couch and i look at the couch where
he was asleep and he wasn't there no
more um
and so then i look over at my buddy
and i remember we were sleeping with a
futon mattress on the floor
and he was right against the wall my
buddy billy was right against the wall
and he had somehow like wiggled his way
between the wall
and billy um and
got a spot next to billy i still didn't
think nothing about it because you know
this is the guy who got me believing in
god
and taught me about god and
was in my life when i was in foster care
you know and a dark moment in my life
um and he
billy got up and went to sleep on the
couch so they're like
i'm awake but i don't know nothing that
went on yet
every like two minutes he's like
scooting over closer to me
then all of a sudden his hand touches me
right here and i'm awake
but i'm acting like i'm asleep and i
don't know what to think like i'd always
heard those rumors and we never believed
15 16 so i'm old enough to know better
um really i was old enough to know
better to let this go farther than what
it did
um so his hands right here and i'm
thinking huh like maybe he's asleep
maybe he don't know or maybe this is his
way of showing me love me you know i
really trust this guy
and then his head like two minutes later
his hands here
i'm thinking like he's got to be asleep
you know i
have no clue what he's uh what he's
think
you know doing right now it's got to be
something uh why he's asleep and he
don't know what he's doing
and then his head goes down and then
like i said i kept having these thoughts
in my head long story short his hand
goes to here
and even when his hand was right there i
had this
like doubt in my mind that that he was
like this you know like
i thought you know he don't know his
hand is there
and then i felt i don't know if the
camera could see my lap
um but i felt this like squeeze and i
was like jumped up like man what the
hell are you doing and he's like act
like he was asleep and rolled over
and uh billy woke up the next morning
and
he left her drive the church bus and we
told him like what happened he
we told each other what happened to each
other one of us and we decided since he
his life revolved around kids and he
always had little kids
smaller than us stay all night with them
like every single night
we decided that the best thing we could
do is go to the people at school and
tell them
so we went to the assistant principal
told him he said don't repeat that
to nobody he said i'm going to get you
to see the real principle we go see
who's also a member of that church me
and billy both telling the story
and he says don't repeat that to nobody
you know don't say nothing to nobody and
nothing ever came of it
and that really really messed my like
view of religion up
it was uh you know it was it was a
really dark moment like i questioned
everything about god the person who had
me believing in god
ended up being a pedophile you know and
nobody cared did he get caught
eventually he's still a school teacher
and he still runs the outreach program
here
and i'm sure by now he's got thousands
of victims
i mean i know a bunch of his victims
also like i've talked to other
you know they didn't get believed just
like i didn't believe him
i'd heard the stories and i was like oh
man you're crazy
um you know and then when it was my turn
nobody believed me neither so
you know he's uh he's a respected member
of the community
but he is a pedophile and he uses his
his like his job and his um spot in the
church
to pick out targets and like i said he
picks the most
vulnerable people he can find the
problematic kids that
he can lie as well nobody's going to
believe him you know that has
issues at home and i'm sure he's even
had a couple of the kids
that he's he's a messed up for life you
know
went a lot further with him that didn't
know better because i
remember even a little kid that was in
he was my foster brother i had to help
him get on the bus every day
having his little sister they're like
five and seven
even a little seven-year-old boy used to
donate with him all the time so
uh you know i'm i'm old enough to know
that a man is not supposed to grab
the youth pastor not supposed to grab my
penis while i'm asleep
but these seven-year-old kids are you
you know they're not ready for that
at all
anything else you'd like get into yeah
that's heavy what
i thought you know you could edit that i
was just giving you what i know man yeah
no it's interesting
um are you
so do you use drugstore yes i do um
i've done suboxone for 10 years
when i got when i went to prison um
i started doing suboxones when i got out
of prison i kept doing them because they
they really are like you know i they're
exactly the same thing as
opiates uh but the thing about it is it
let me have control of my life like i
didn't have to chase drugs every day
i could do some of the morning and not
worry about drugs every day and then uh
for the last two months i've failed i've
went backwards
and i've done heroin for the last two
months
um i had a house fire you know there's
no excuse for it i had but i've had a
house fire and some thefts
from my business in my house
after it was on fire everything that
didn't burn was stolen
um and so
i i am using drugs i use uh heroin every
day
are you married are you kids i don't i'm
not married and i don't have no kids
you're still young yet so you can
straighten your life out and
yeah you know i'm i'm
i do prefer suboxones over the heroin
um the only thing is is you can't go
from
um heroin to suboxone
instantly like uh like i said i've only
done it for two months
um in the first three or four weeks of
it i was doing some boxing and heroin
and i actually done it because i had a
toothache um so i'd done some heroin
i had a agonizing two things so i'd done
some hoping it would make
my mother actually gave it to me um you
know
so that's another story but um she
actually offered it to me and she's been
on
it she was down here been caught for
traffic in in clay county
multiple times but why do you think
drugs are so prevalent here
in appalachia because yeah i've been in
west west virginia many times and it's
everywhere there as well yeah you know
there's definitely a reason for that um
people want to you know escape um this
is
like there's this is a really simple
lifestyle down here
uh you know you can live down here with
no money like
people are really good people down here
um you know as
as crazy as it is a lot of them are on
drugs
but if you're hitchhiking you can get a
ride down here if you don't
know where to stay you can stay with
your neighbor down here like people
um everybody knows everybody and it's
like family
down here you know so um
and but the reason people are on drugs
is because
they have nothing else to turn to you
know
um everybody wants to feel good in the
city there's all kinds of things you can
go
to make you feel good you can go to the
movies and hang out with friends and
down here uh you can't do that there's
no movie theater there's no place for
kids other than church and like i said
if you're down here you might want to
keep your kids out of this
church down here um and
drugs is like what everybody turns to
and then
i like i said they call this the city of
hope
i remember one time somebody took some
spray paint and knocked off the h
and put a d there they and made it to
say the sun that coming in say the city
of dope
um and drugs are worth a lot more money
down here
um than they are in the city so when
drugs been worth a lot more money
even in the city i know people like oh
i'm getting i'm buying all the drugs up
and i'm bringing them down here
a lot of people transport their drugs
down here because they are worth more
money i'll tell you something else down
here like um
even the police like i was talking about
the government
are you from were you familiar with any
of that before you came like our mayor
getting locked up for
sex being a sex offender and uh he was
sleeping like a 13 year old girl we had
18
of our elected officials arrested at one
time and that's actually when my dad
um i told you my dad sold one pill
that's actually why he ended up getting
arrested too caught up in the election
fraud um
and he actually was one of the people
who couldn't get away from
that got away from the election fraud
and the feds don't like to lose so they
came back and got him for anything they
could that was
he he actually gave a pill to a guy um
who had a camera on him and showed the
guy good
uh the guy said to my dad like there's
people out
acting crazy these days and my dad
pulled out a gun and said let them out
crazy around here
uh you know i got something for him and
like i said he gave the guy a pill the
guy said his back was hurting
there wasn't no major pills or lure said
or something you know like
a 10 or 15 pill down here very minor
pill um and
so he wore the camera and the wire and
they see my dad
have the gun uh give the guy a pill
and also snore the pill with the guy so
they charge them with like
drug drug abuse by um
by a gun owner or something like that i
guess uh having a gun and even doing a
drug like where he snorted it
uh what was that charge i can't remember
the charge
but he also got charged with like a
career armed criminal
because when he was 18 years old he hit
a guy with an extinguisher
and uh stole a hundred dollars for me
and then got robbery and that was when i
was born he was in the
hospital for for that i was actually
conceived in the um
in the jail down here my uncle was the
jailer
before my dad went to prison my uncle
let him go out to this little picnic
area
and that's where i was conceived so my
dad tells me right before
he went away interesting yeah
all right matthew well thank you so much
for sharing your interesting story yeah
man
yeah okay because i don't you know i
don't want to get anybody in trouble but
man that's
okay i'll say we get that guy in trouble
man that might be what i mean if i
might be another whole documentary uh
getting into something like that like
documenting the you know that's a big
topic right now
um sex sex offended people with power
yeah which this nobody here's got the
kind of power that
is